greg abbott gobernador de texas se
atribuyó la responsabilidad de enviar
dos buses llenos de inmigrantes en su
mayoría venezolanos acá a la residencia
de la vicepresidenta kamala harris lo
hace porque según él la vicepresidenta
niega que hay una crisis en la frontera
a los inmigrantes les están prometiendo
trabajo vivienda y mejor vida los montan
en buses o aviones hacia ciudades del
norte de eeuu con gobiernos demócratas
este fue el caso de los inmigrantes que
terminaron en martha's vineyard una isla
de turismo en massachusetts donde
normalmente van demócratas y
progresistas esta práctica de mandar
minorías inmigrantes desde estados del
sur a estados del norte no es nueva en
eeuu durante la época de segregación a
principios de los 90 estados como
luisiana enviaban a afroamericanos al
norte del país en lo que llamaban las
caravanas de liberación inversa se
calcula que más de 10.000 inmigrantes
indocumentados han llegado a washington
en las últimas semanas y la alcaldesa de
la ciudad murió bowser ha decretado el
estado de emergencia para responder y
atender con más recursos a estas
personas